hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
the Saranac school was started by
aristipus a student of Socrates and it
had a primarily hedonistic point of view
or orientation and there were several
reinterpreters of this school in its
history one of the most interesting of
which who's talked about bi-diaginase
Laertes in book six of his lives of the
philosophers is this guy
theodorus and we find that you know he's
studied with several different people
and he's bringing some new points of
view into Syrian act philosophy and
probably the most important of which is
sort of a modification of the conception
of what the end or the the goal the
scopos the Telos of life actually is the
thing that we should fundamentally
Orient ourselves by so a hedonistic
School takes Pleasure and Pain to be the
primary the things that are
fundamentally motivating us everything
else needs to be evaluated in terms of
those and you could say that perhaps
theodorus's reinterpretation takes us
somewhat away from Hedonism in some
important respects
not least because he says that Joy
Harris in in Greek it's an emotion right
and grief is how it's translated here
Lupe which we can also translate as pain
but interestingly in the discussions of
the Sierra named school it's other terms
besides Lupe that have been used
primarily for example ponos and Al gaze
right so joy and grief or being upset
are the ends the good end and the bad
end of life and he's going to identify
wisdom and Justice as actual Goods
Agatha with joy and wisdom is integral
to promoting Joy he goes on and he
actually says it's brought about by
wisdom or you know it's in accordance
with wisdom you might say and then the
opposite habits so what are the opposite
habits to wisdom and Justice uh
foolishness
right and Injustice are the evils that
bring about grief and so the idea seems
to be here because it's not sketched out
in great detail that by behaving wisely
by behaving justly you will enjoy Joy
you will enjoy a good life and if you're
instead motivated by the Opposites then
you're going to have grief
and then interestingly enough so we've
got you know goods and evils Agatha and
Kaka pleasure hey donay and Payne ponos
are said to be middle States they're not
said to be indifferent but they are
intermediate to Good and Evil you could
say so they're somehow neutral or in
between and this seems to be taking us
away from
a much more direct Hedonism and towards
a more sophisticated type you could say
so that's one main reinterpretation
another one that was quite important for
discussion how do hedonists look at
friendship philia in Greek and this
doesn't just name like close friends
this name's all of these relationships
where we might call somebody you know a
friend a companion a lover all those
sorts of things and we find that
theodorus actually Rejects
friendship for some interesting reasons
you get the idea that this is a person
who liked to argue quite a bit and
whether or not the arguments were
particularly good he would make them as
we see with some of the arguments that
he has said to have uh made which are
real sophisms but the rejection of
friendship
it doesn't exist he claims between the
wise and the unwise right
but it also doesn't exist between the
unwise themselves and it also doesn't
exist between the wise themselves so why
not well because the unwise like he's
going to say
um whatever we're going to call
friendship uh it goes away when the need
or use is removed taken away the
uh then the unwise cease to be friends
with each other they start behaving in
different ways towards each other right
they're like well don't need you anymore
you're not helpful or you know maybe it
could be in terms of pleasure I'm not
enjoying the pleasure of your company or
enjoying having sex with you or enjoying
uh playing games with you no more
friendship right the whys on the other
hand he claims are going to be
self-sufficient
right this is a very important term for
ancient Greek philosophy
we typically translate as
self-sufficiency it's having what you
need and so the wise they've already got
everything they need for a good life so
they don't actually need friends and
because of that they're not going to
waste their time or spend their time
trying to make friends trying to
cultivate friendships they're already
good as they are and perhaps you know if
theyodorus is an example of this himself
he's also famous for having said that
he's a citizen of the world this notion
of cosmopolitanism that we see being
important in other schools for example
the cynic school and the stoic School
but he's also got some interesting
things about seemingly wrong actions
things that we would typically say are
bad to do like stealing right so theft
is a bad action adultery a very you know
dimly looked at in the ancient world and
adultery means basically screwing
anybody who already is connected with
with somebody else so you could be an
adulterer by having sex with somebody
else who's married even if you're not
married
sacrilege the the word there is
literally it references the holy right
or the sacred
to you know mess around with holy things
and he says that these are
okay sometimes Chiron right so in the
right time these are admissible now why
is that the case
well because he thinks that nothing is
really right or wrong
per se but it's really a matter of there
being sort of a prejudice against them
they're not shameful they're not things
that we should be embarrassed about once
we remove that prejudice that doke say
from them why well because we keep these
up this this Prejudice in order to hold
as he says the foolish multitude
together the the people who don't know
much of anything or perhaps even think
themselves wise even though they're not
they need to be kept in check
and we see here that this is kind of
similar to what was said about the
Sirenix Sage they don't actually need
rules the rules are for the ordinary
people because the ordinary people are
are misguided
he also makes a similar uh line of
argument
about what is okay and what's not which
is a little bit more developed and
interestingly in the translation here a
little bit of prudishness they actually
left out a couple lines so he's got this
argument
is a woman who's skilled in grammar
useful in so far she's skilled in
grammar and so the person says yes is a
boy or a youth skilled in grammar useful
insofar as they're skilled and grammar
yes and gramaticos is the word there
literally somebody who can do grammar
correctly so there's a kind of
usefulness in that the kind of goodness
a kind of you know benefit to to other
people and then he changes the topic
slightly what about a woman who is
beautiful is she useful in so far as she
is beautiful and they say yes and then
well what about a youth or
um you know a boy yes as well and is the
use of beauty to be enjoyed and they say
yes and then when this was admitted he
would press the argument to the
conclusion the person who uses anything
for the purpose for which it is useful
does no wrong and the the language here
is a little bit complicated here
he he says
80s Place yasmo Romanos the person who's
using uh the thing that they have you
know approached the thing that they are
making use of
um
in accordance or along the lines of what
it is useful for
today right they don't thereby Dia do
something wrong they don't sin is
another way they don't uh morally air so
you know what are the implications of
this well anything that's got a proper
use if you're using it for that so you
know what would it be for beauty uh
perhaps you know enjoying the company of
the person right having them hanging
around
um you know perhaps having sex with with
them or other sorts of pleasurable Joy
inspiring activities well then that
would be the proper use according to
theodorus right and this could go
against social mores just as much as the
seeming other seemingly wrong actions so
we can think of you know should you have
adult should you commit adulterous
relations with the beautiful woman well
you know what are beautiful people for
and we could make this uh gender uh
neutral as well any person who's
attractive even if they're involved in a
relationship or you know we can think
about theft right
I I like this thing over here that
person's not really using it I'll go
take it and use it for myself theodorus
would say that that is okay and so you
know this this really does seem to be a
little bit at odds with the fact that
it's wisdom and Justice that are the
goods
um it's a rather unusual kind of wisdom
you know freeing oneself of social
um expectations and restrictions and you
can say well how how is this connected
with Justice and Injustice and there
isn't an answer in this little summary
here and then you know what else do we
learn about the guy there's a few
anecdotes told about him where you know
he's making rather sophistical arguments
and we don't need to worry an awful lot
about that but these are the
distinctives of the Theodore and
reinterpretation of the serenaic ethics
and what it was that his you know school
and followers actually taught and
thought